he was a massive figure in the world of
theoretical physics and many people
would have heard of him and yet I think
it'd be fair to say that his work led to
the probably three Nobel prizes being
awarded lot daily not to him not to him
and he could have been involved in
certainly at least two of them I think
he could have if things that had turned
out differently he was actually born in
1932 in India in Madras - I think
British parents who were working over in
India he came back to Scotland to be
educated at college in Scotland and he
spent his undergraduate and postgraduate
time at Edinburgh University and then I
think he went over to Caltech for a
period for a year before securing a
position Imperial College and back in
the late 50s at Imperial and he'd stayed
there till till he died so I knew him
through the through his work on
cosmology and then that required a
knowledge of particle physics and that
in turn requires a detailed knowledge of
quantum field theory tom was a pioneer
of that field the word that he developed
the techniques he developed have
applications not only in particle
physics cosmology but also in condensed
matter physics and so he was able to
develop an area of physics which is sort
of the interface between condensed
matter and cosmology as well as his
pioneering work involving the Higgs
particle early universe phase
transitions symmetry breaking gravity
there was one thing I discovered he
worked in 1961 I wrote a paper in which
he looked at a modification of general
relativity that thought recently that
I've been seeing references to this
paper of Tom's 1961 and I just looked
back in ninth in 2015 it had over a
hundred citations this paper he wrote
you know that's the kind of impact he
had across the fields he was able to
write things and it lay dormant for a
while and then people realized wow this
is really impressive stuff
the first and the one that sixty symbols
viewers will know most about is probably
the Higgs right the discovery of the
Higgs back in 2012 I think which led to
the Nobel Prize in 2013 the mechanism
which is known as the Higgs mechanism
was developed independently by three
groups one of those groups involved Tom
he wrote a paper that was published in
Physical Review Letters and that has
become one of their flagship papers that
they often cite as being one of their
key contributions to the journal and he
wrote it with his friends Gorrell Nick
and Hagen and because of this crazy law
rule that we discussed that the only
that the Nobel Prize can only go to
three people they decided I guess they
couldn't just give it to Tom and not
give it to the other two they were
giving it to Higgs and on glair quite
rightly so Tom missed out Tom wrote a
second probably even more influential
paper he actually was the person that
demonstrated how you can use this
mechanism in the proper world of
particle physics in the end that we knew
that one of the key particles in nature
is the W and Z vector boson these tell
us about how the weak interactions
behave these are very massive particles
we didn't know how to give these masses
and Tom is the person that actually
demonstrated how you do this he came up
with the actual mathematical formalism
to introduce masses to these particles
this then in 1967 he wrote this paper so
three years after the Higgs mechanism he
applied it to this realistic situation
provided the breakthrough that helped
Weinberg understand the standard model
of particle physics and Salam so
Weinberg and Salam shared the Nobel
Prize with it's a clash alpha for the
standard model of particle physics it
also had a knock-on effect that the
formalism that Tom had developed in this
1967 paper the very mathematical
formalism helped to hoof to envelopment
understand that this model standard
model was what they call renormalizable
this means that you can make actual
predictions with the model basically but
the the formalism that that Tom had
developed helped them
they then got the Nobel Prize as well
and of course you also have the fact
that Tom independently and Discoverer
the Higgs mechanism in 1964 which got
the Nobel Prize for Higgs and ungli so 3
no praxis came out of work directly
related to Tom I found it kind of the
most humbling experience I think I've
seen that day when when the Nobel Prize
was announced first of all the delay you
might recall there was a delay of over
an hour and it turned out the delay was
that were trying to find Higgs but to
let him know but people would think of
well maybe they told Tom and Tom has
turned it down because he would have
known that if he got it his two
collaborators wouldn't have got it that
wasn't the case but I have read since
Tom told his son Robert that he was
actually quite relieved not to have got
the prize because if he had have got the
prize it would have been at the expense
of his close friends and collaborators
of the of the original paper well that's
that's what Tom thought so I guess you
have to go with his wishes but what do
you think about the fact he never got a
Nobel Prize I mean he did with a lot of
prizes he did win a lot of prizes he is
recognized as being a you know a giant
in this field I think it's sad that they
didn't get it but I fully appreciate his
his attitude and his I believe it you
know the day of the when the prizes were
announced he was being interviewed all
over the place and you didn't hear a
single word of bitterness or criticism
the closest I got where it was he said
well if they have these archaic rules
for the award the Nobel Prize he can't
get it but he met I knew him quite well
it was a good friend and collaborator
and he never ever complained or said
anything and derogatory about the award
of the prize never what do you think he
was bringing to the table that made him
so exceptional what was his sort of
unique selling point or his skill good
what was Tom's thing oh okay so I was I
was actually thinking about this - their
feeling of coming in I think a
mathematically incredibly strong he knew
detailed mathematics about areas known
as group theory in homotopy theory these
play essential roles in food for example
his understanding of group theories and
non abelian gauge theories allowed here
to understand how this vector boson
could acquire a mass for the W whilst
the the photon remained masters it was
Tom that realized this and so he brought
this very detailed mathematical
knowledge of quantum mechanics quantum
field theory group Theory homotopy
theory to the table coupled with this
deep understanding of the physical side
he would when I worked with him he would
always be asking about the physical
consequences of a calculation you know
does it make sense physically we're
dealing with objects that are meant to
be in the universe does it make sense
can we already rule it out and so he was
a physicist but with a very mouth of
strong mathematical bent and that I
think was this unique thing that he what
other people have it but he had it in
this particular combination which was
just right he was kind he was gentle
it was never afraid to tell you if he
thought you were wrong he was determined
to get things as accurately as possible
the number of you know I worked with him
on quite a few papers I was privileged
to do that and the number of iterations
of papers where we would be discussing
words there a bit a level of words are
we saying this right and the
calculations we would check double check
he was really rigorous in his approach
but he had time for everyone there are
so many stories of Tom being sort of
people banging on his door when he was
head of department Imperial and coming
in almost off the street some people to
tell him their ideas and he would listen
and he would listen to them and then he
would he probably said I don't know if
it's rather than dismiss things but he
would always listen he always had time
young scientists like when I arrived
imperials a 24 year old 25 year old he
had so much time for people and to
listen and offer them advice that there
is a little story that might be worth
telling you about I I got invited to
give a seminar Imperial they were
considering a pyrrha me for a postdoc I
was a Newcastle doing a PhD and it
wasn't in the area Tom worked so I
worked really hard on the presentation
it was the time of transparencies I'm I
made it way too technical as new people
knew
spiritually students do because I would
try to impress so I went down and gave
this talk and it blew everyone away
because which is too technical apart
from the few experts who already knew it
so it wasn't great and then after the
talk Tom went off he didn't ask any
questions he went off to his room
because he was head of department and my
friend ray Rivers said well you should
go meet Tom you know he's famous guy and
you might be you might be here as a
postdoc so I went to his office and sat
down in his office and he was at his
table he smiled and he didn't say
anything nothing and I'm thinking oh
okay
and whew what felt like minutes went by
and eventually I said well it's me who's
come to see him and I should say
something so I said well professor
kibble I know you're a very important
person really respect your work and
would like to know what did you think we
got any advice for me I'm just starting
and he looked anyway don't write in
yellow stuff all no transparencies all
my equations I'd written in yellow none
of them had projected to the book so
every single equation nobody could see
not so not only was it really technical
talk nobody could see an equation then
that was his bit of advice and then we
then we chatted a bit more and in fact
we began a collaboration a couple of
years later when I returned him to the
UK and where we had a fantastic time but
he was just a Robinson your talk was
just a rubbish it was not right in
yellow did you ever bring that up with
him but he was like you said you're a
few rows like they just smiled as he
would hey you know he would Tom you
wasn't afraid of silence he didn't feel
the need he would never try and dominate
he hated being the center of attention
he just didn't want it hate it but he
would always be prepared to tell you you
know give his thoughts on something if
you wanted to know but so you could go
for tea with Tom and not say anything
it'd be fine and initially it's a bit
felt that awkward but then you realize I
know it's fine and then you just say
something I need reply and it was all it
was all right
you can't help you then give it to three
more once I realized they haven't got it
I just texted him and said then I'm very
sorry to hear you didn't get I think you
deserved it
and he replied he replied almost
immediately and he just said thanks very
much he's such a nice guy you didn't say
I got asked people